you
[Music]
hello everybody it is my great pleasure
my great pleasure to introduce Nick
cauldre who is our visiting researcher
we're delighted be able to have him for
another month or so two months that's
excellent and he comes to us from the
London School of Economics and political
science and what did all of the great
work of being a chair of the media
communication department and now has
time to continue his writing because he
is one of the most prolific writers in
our field so I think this is going he's
working on book 9 or 10 I don't even
know anymore I hate you and and we're
really excited to have him here thinking
about just fundamental questions about
the compatibility of big data collection
and democracy you know small topic so
with that thank you very much for
joining us okay okay thank you Mary it's
great to be here I'm having a great time
at Microsoft I recommend it to anyone
watching this later on the online
version it's a it's a good deal it's a
very good deal I'm very happy and I
won't want it to end
but I'll try and introduce you in 3035
minutes into some of the themes that
I've been working on here
there'll be themes from a joint book
that I'm writing with Ulysses making s
for Stanford University Press
the provisional title is the costs of
connection but I'm sure it won't end up
being called that and I'm going to talk
about what they call two problems that
arise in thinking about the site types
of social order we're now living in the
age of big data and I use the word
problem not in the sense of something
we've got to fix right now but in the
sense of like the problem of free will
in philosophy it's something that we're
going to be thinking about puzzling
about all of us coming at from different
directions probably for generations
that's the scale of problem I think
we're dealing with in relation to
knowledge and freedom and to get started
I just want to go back particularly if
maybe we you heard my whiteboard talk
that's about six weeks ago you didn't
but anyway to give you the starting
point of how I approach
theory at all so my broad interest is
their relations between media in a very
broad sense including information data
collection everything we now come back
into that word media and communication
generally and something we might still
want to call society the Sun see I put
it in scare quotes because I'm not
assuming a neatly functioning order
within national boundaries that's absurd
now we're not talking about that but we
are talking about processes of ordering
something like the social so it feels
social which is called the social and
we're talking about the role in that
ordering of media infrastructures in the
broadest possible sense and I think
that's a issue for social theory which
is also an issue for economic theory but
the double theory we all assume some
minimal level order without which we
wouldn't be able to talk about any other
things we want to talk about in doing
science and doing social science and I'm
particularly interested in the
consequences for social order in this
broad sense of the fundamental
completely banal fad today which is
absolutely astonishing which is the
embedding of
computing power and therefore two-way or
multi way connection that's possible
through computing power at every point
in space
and because information is archived at
every point in space time creating
utterly new types of feedback loops
which we have not even begun to theorize
that's the problem I'm interested in and
at the very least that's sort of deep
embedding of computer power power
relations if you like creates new forms
of dependence on computing systems
obviously which is the basis of business
models new forms of social
interdependence and since no
interdependence comes without tension
tensions social tensions which we need
to seriously think about and if you like
also a new type of social
complexity how can we think about this
multi-dimensional order that has to be
arising somehow in the middle of all
this change that's the thing I'm
interested in and I just want to
introduce from my previous book the
media Deakin construction of reality one
concept that I think is useful I won't
refer back to it in detail later on but
it will give you a flavor of how I think
about this sort of complexity and I
talked about it briefly in the
whiteboard talk and that's a concept
from the German theorist often neglected
now in Britain and the state's Norbert
Elias it was a refugee from Nazi Germany
and there's a lot of his life in Britain
we've developed a concept of social
complexity which he called figurations
and figurations is interesting because
it's very different from the concept we
tend to rely on to understand complexity
today which is networks everyone
understands the network sets of nodes
physical links or informational links
which create more complex networks pace
may be extremely complex
now Elias was also interested in
networks but he added a crucial
ingredient which is that they were
dynamic that they were lattice works of
tensions in other words at each point in
space there's an entity that's pulling
the entity at the other end of that line
in the network their dynamic and their
dynamic because there's meaning and
content there's something at stake in
the network that creates a totally
different type of dynamic tension from
the one we can theorize the notion of
networks which is apparently our most
advanced concept for complexity but I
think barely even gets going and
thinking about complexity he said the
behavior of so many of many separate
people into meshes it's like a fence a
wire fence pulling to create the
strength of the fence to form into woven
structures I just want to illustrate
that in a diagram so here's from our
book you can see that's much more than
the network of course because each
entity is pulling on the other it's not
just link is pulling
and of course each person in the
grouping it could be a game of cards a
game of football could be a corporation
is being themselves pulled in multiple
directions by other spaces in society so
in other words already even in this
simple concept and that's our version of
elias's diagram from the early 1970s
that's how advanced he was and he's
thinking about complexity already that
implies a multi-dimensional order
attention in higher dimensions which
results from this apparently one
dimension or two dimensional plane
which is interesting just to go back a
second the question then is taking his
concept from the late 70s and actually
how already had the ideas in the early
30s which makes it even more astonishing
how can we think about social order in
higher dimensions really higher
dimensions when we take account of all
the institutions in society what we call
in that previous book figurations of
figurations well here's a diagram of how
that would look like so you have the
initial figuration which already implies
higher dimensions but in itself the
overall push or tension or weight if
you're like a bet figuration is itself
being pulled by other institutional
forces so if we think about Facebook as
an institutions of figuration of
Federation's the group of people
designing policy and Facebook are human
beings like the rest of us doing the
best to solve whatever they have to
solve and they have their own personal
histories but they're of course being
pulled by the economic forces which are
the basis of the business model which in
turn is being pulled by the brand and
all the social tensions that creates to
represent Facebook in certain ways which
in turn is being pulled by government
law and so on not ad infinitum but on
many many dimensions we're looking at
hundreds of dimensions pulling together
creating an extremely complex type of
order so let's
but that's in the background and now
think about two particular problems but
before I get on to my problems just one
more bit of introduction we like to
think of course particularly in media
studies which sometimes presents us our
studying what's right now what's
absolutely new and we like to think
where no one has ever thought about
these problems before but of course
that's not true the whole history of
social theory has been puzzling it at
different moments of trying to say what
the hell is going on here we don't have
the concepts for this this is what
generated sociology in the first place
is what generated the crisis is
sociology in the 60s and so on and so
forth so can we find any parallels for
the sorts of radical transformations
we're seeing today well we can there's a
great book from the 80s James manages
the control revolution which you may not
know if communication since you're Arab
I strongly recommend it because it's one
of the very few books that starts out
from the basis that communications that
sort of little area we look at through
the lens of Media Studies it's actually
the site where all sorts of other forces
are being pulled they happen to generate
things like the telegraph system
newspapers but that's because of all
these intersecting forces that operate
through them that make them necessary
that sustain them that generate crisis
through them so he sees communications
at the sides of an intersection of
massive rats social and economic change
crossing areas such as transport spatial
organization business to give you the
simple example from his book which
everyone quotes because it's so vivid
he explained that at a certain point it
was important to send the news down the
railway line that the train was coming
because there only was one line and what
if a train was coming the other way
there are many accidents when the I'd
the ability to send the message down the
line and to do it in an ordered precise
way that was effective had not yet been
planned and developed
that's a very simple way of how new
Transport Paulo possibilities require
absolutely new communication ineffective
structures which itself links into
economics business and so on so that's
interesting so can we think about
today's problems there's also what
Benedict called problems of control and
just to throw in one other example
because it's a illustration of the sort
of great conversations I'm having here
in in Microsoft tomorrow in our reading
group on radical social theory we're
discussing another great historical
parallel which would be karl polanyi's
work who's bought the great
transformation which was on the
emergence of markets in the early 19th
century and industrial capitalism and
how that didn't just happen because
markets were somehow natural and just
waiting waiting to be pulled out of the
box but the sorts of assumptions that
make a market possible oh if I do that
you were of course going to do that in
return had to be socially constructed
they had to be built and many of that
much of that building was very painful
and difficult because it went against
previous assumptions and the way the
economy worked so Polanyi is another
example but taking those two together
both of them bring out for me but even
if your interest is economics or let's
say government how the social is
constructed how it comes to be socially
possible that human entities who could
be doing other things interact that way
is enormously important so I will want
to argue that social theory whether it's
done well or badly is potentially very
important contribution to economic
theory political theory and government
and so on so that's what I'm gonna think
about so I want to move on now to the
what they're calling the knowledge
problem in the age of big data I don't
need to say any more about what big data
is it's in the popular discourse and all
of us in many of us in this room are
experts in what it means in terms of
practices of collecting and processing
data and beyond that the stories were
telling ourselves about the new types of
knowledge we're getting of this social
through Big Data there's a lot of myth
making about what Big Data is doing to
the social or there's a lot of serious
thinking about what Big Data could do to
genuinely transform our knowledge of the
social world all that on top of the
practices themselves so let's think
about this problem what do I mean by
this social I've always asked this oh I
get this on the table right away the
social is not something I can neatly
define because it cannot be neatly
defined but it's the word we use to
point at that massive domain of human
activity which is based in interactions
and connections without which we can't
have anything like human life we can
have a few people existing in some way
for a few hours or months in the desert
and dying utterly wretched and
successful but anything recognizable a
successful human life requires
interaction connection and that's what
we're pointing to when we use the word
social there is no better definition
then I got that from william sealy
chicago's social theorist but that's
just a starter a few interesting
questions when we think about this
knowledge problem because social
knowledge isn't just our knowledge of
each other as individuals that's
essential but it's half the stories we
tell about the social overall because
they're part of how we situate each of
our lives
so we already get into a high order
problem what is social knowledge there's
the meta problem in other words of how
the social world knows itself at all but
not just in it we have accounts of it on
the basis of which we say you can't do
that that's unacceptable or things can't
work that way I have a right therefore
to challenge that so social knowledge
exists in various dimensions and there's
always a neglected level as well which
Pierre Bourdieu was one of the first
people to point out and the book in the
70s we forget that
social science itself is knowledge like
all knowledge has to be produced humans
have to be in institutions very often
they have to travel to the right place
they need tools and so on there's always
the hidden social conditions of
producing what we know about the social
and we need a sociology to understand
that too so there's many dimensions to
how we come to know the social at all
and those dimensions are now changing
and there's a tendency always which
bored you're pointed out to ignore those
underlying conditions which shape what
can be knowledge of the social we assume
we just know we just see right in there
but that possibility of seeing right
into things is itself socially produced
linked to various forms of expertise
privilege institutional resource and so
on which are really important especially
when that ability to see things is
changing as it is right now and we can
also think about how the knowledge of
those conditions under which social
knowledge is produced is it is
deliberately made up a very often we
don't always want people to see into the
engine room to see how we claim to see
the world because that would lead to
challenge and I think we're in a stage
where the certain things are very opaque
about the new types of knowledge so I
want to come back on to that now this is
where I think historical comparison
becomes really useful because and I've
been working on this a lot while I've
been here because if we just start off
on what we have now it's bewildering
very fast changing and therefore the
natural thing is say well let's go with
those who are doing the work and follow
what they say but then we have no
historical comparison at all we have no
sense of whether previous societies have
gone through similar things and if they
have didn't work out radically
differently and that's what I want to
suggest you for the few minutes that the
comparison with the 19th century to
early 20th century leads to some very
surprising differences from where we are
today
I won't go into the detail the history
statistics is not my expertise but I
really lot of the books by those who are
experts and it throws up some very
interesting differences so in the early
19th century late 18th century there was
a radical shift in the knowledge of the
social particularly in Europe and North
America so the world shifted from one in
which there was human nature which was
largely fixed and written about from
Aristotle and there was human variation
individuals were of course slightly
variable but we didn't know much about
that in in therefore it wasn't very
interesting and nothing ordered or
structured could be said about it that
was all there was so there wasn't really
much of a development of social science
statistics based on counting gathering
data counting starting to reserve
numerical and statistical patterns
radically change what could be said
about the social and many would argue
actually created the possibility of a
social of the idea there was something
ordered out there which was the social
and this was a complex social and of
course highly political process as Ted
Porter one of the leading historians of
numbers statistics writes the
credibility of numbers doesn't just
exist it's a social and moral problem
people fight over which numbers are
better who has the right to generate
numbers and apply them to the world
power must be exercised in a variety of
ways to make the measurements and
tallies valid well I think it's pretty
obvious we're in such a moment of
history right now there's a massive
battle going on about the measurements
and the tallies and he also says that
when a power game is won and certain
measurements and tallies become
normative they are very effective in
changing the world in certain ways or is
he in hacking puts in another great book
ways of making up people making people
who can now be talked about in new ways
and we are going in into it and you
detail those of you in economics will
obviously know the history was the
emergence of extraordinary new ideas of
the average the normal person around
which statistical variation always
tended to vary this was an extraordinary
concept the statistical norm and that
was based in very material tools putting
data together in packages that could be
then talked about as one thing the idea
of the map which had data encoded into
it
a great example because I see if I walk
around the geography department at LSE
they still have it on the walls this
Charles booth map of London poverty
based on his discovery of eight
dimensions of poverty which came out of
statistical analysis and it was pulled
up on the wall and all sorts of
Institute so we can think about how
London is organized some recent
interesting recent history of my dad
about his story near the insurance
industry on this which is very parallel
to what we're going through today the
emergence of new data aggregates so
that's if you like in a snapshot it what
lambda Rho C or another writer about
statistics calls the concrete history of
abstraction abstraction doesn't just
come from though it has to be built in
particular resources it's hard to miss
speak abstractly and get it to stick on
the world some what are the parallels
today we're like just to sum up what my
arguments going to be and I'll go
through some more detail in a moment
I think today's massive explosion of
social knowledge through Big Data has
two very distinctive features compared
with the 19th century the first is the
depth almost infinite depth and the
continuity the ABS absolute continuity
of which data is collected this has no
parallel in the 19th century there were
censuses every 10 years there were
various other tools to gathering data
where you could put it together somehow
there was nothing remotely similar to
the depth and continuity we now take for
granted
and secondly who's gathering the date
who controls the data on what terms as
we'll see it's very different today from
the way it was in the 19th century
they're just going a bit more detail the
point about continuity as I said data in
the 19th century was gathered
episodically therefore there was no N
equal to all N equals all was
unimaginable there was M was relatively
small a might include the whole country
if you could compel people to fill in
the census but that was only every 10
years and the gap in between was not
insurance insurance companies tried to
do better than that but there were
limits to what they could do
the key point though I think is that
social knowledge today is increasingly
generated by private capacities I call
them capacities because it's not just
corporations any business that starts up
to date almost certainly has in its
business model creating a platform with
apps linked to apps and API is to gather
data either for its own purposes or to
sell that data on or to somehow make
itself valuable to other corporations
because it has that data so the
collection of data is built into almost
any business model today any private
business model States and public's are
also involved but most of the data is
privately gathered and that's important
it's also important to this woman not
just talking about capacities we're
talking about the values which govern
the collection of data I was struck in
Ted Porter's book he discusses a debate
in the 19th century in France where
there was the statistical Association of
France which said the reason we need
statistics is to defend public values
against private values if we get a
picture of the hole which we can through
statistics then we can answer the
private interests who want to dominate
society one way or the other
I think it's obvious that that is
radically different from the official
goals of collections
although there are exceptions which I'll
come back to another key point is the
opacity of gathering knowledge today
this I'm sure there are many things
which remain too obscure people obscure
to people about the statistics in the
19th century obviously but in broad
terms
these were information that was gathered
publicly through public means and was
able open to public debate
so insurers had a few means on the basis
of which they wrote the premiums for
people wanting insurance policies and
when it became obviously known that they
gave different premiums to black people
versus white people it wasn't a very
difficult inference to say their race
had something to do with it and there
were fierce contests in the United
States about that there were not so many
variables involved today there are
disputes about these things but as we
know it's not so easy to challenge wipe
in a particular way an algorithm has
presented this in your newsfeed today
and presented that in your newsfeed
yesterday also this led to very
interesting new debates about things
which inherently public what is poverty
there was a notion that emerged under
gathering various statistical
information aggregating it to talk about
a new thing poverty as something which
was socially determined socially shaped
not just down to fate not just curable
by charity something that could socially
be attacked because it was understood
statistically that is very that produced
public debates about the outputs of data
which is very different I think from
what Frank Pasquale in his recent book
talks of as the generation of data
behind us or the one-way mirror I talked
about booths poverty map before and of
course we know that although in the past
two data was used to discriminate
against people of course there was also
the main emphasis was on social
generalizations trying to understand
society itself that goes on today but as
we know the principal purpose of data
collection today is to dis to
make differentiations as data always
does and to do it to change the actions
which corporations can take which is to
discriminate discriminating
particularity z' it's true that some of
the people in the marketing industry in
the data industry will tell you
something different that's a quote from
a recent book on the marketing industry
that the truths very soon will be
present in everything if we're all
wearing devices which are measuring
everything about us communicating with
other things the truth will be right
there
easily accessible you'll know everything
about yourself and your loved ones if
you opt in actually I think that's very
misleading view about that the
development actually we're talking about
much more particular stories today and I
think it's interesting again we go back
to the public-private thing if you know
anything about 19th century and
statistics one of the key debates at
that time in the public realm it even
reached Charles Dickens novel hard times
was the earth question of freedom if it
was true there was an average man as
they called it statistical norm where
was free will some people argued that
there was no free will that we were
condemned just to play out the average
just in our particular bodies others
argue fiercely that the individual
remain free we were just talking a
statistical pattern at the general level
this was one of the biggest debates
about statistics which were about one of
the fundamental questions in philosophy
free will I don't yet see debates about
the significance of big data on that
philosophical a normative level but
those were normal in the 19th century
and that's an interesting difference but
it leads to another point about what I
call conditionality of course the state
could compel you to answer a census in a
way in the sense were compelled to give
in certain information where we want to
join a platform but I think the
conditionality was different
as I said this was much less frequent
the data the gathering of data and also
it's now part of an individual deal we
all do to get access to a platform type
of information we just have to give us
amount of information and we consent to
certain terms and conditions it's almost
a very pervasive conditionality that's
extremely hard to opt-out of and that
has consequences right across our lives
in a way that the gathering of data by
the 19th century state did not because
the state was much weaker that's the
general comparison let's just move on to
the sort of questions that emerge into
what I'm calling the problem of
knowledge today the first sort of thing
is which I can't answer of course
because no one can yet is what sort of
social will this new model of social
knowledge production what sort of social
will it produce in the long run will
there be a parallel to what we had in
the 19th century that will invent a
totally new concept like poverty to
radically see into the social world
change the politics of the social well
with so many sources of knowledge in
private hands I'm not seeing many signs
of that yet but it is a valid question
we don't know what sort of social will
be generated but we can be sure a
different social will be generated from
this very new type of source of
knowledge that raises questions of
legitimacy which are again unfathomable
no social knowledge can be generated and
be effective unless people trust it and
people trust and respect the authority
of those gathering the data to do so and
the way they use categorizations there
are a lot of disputes about the way
certain algorithms work right now
particularly in u.s. politics we don't
know the consequences of those from the
legitimacy of algorithmic knowledge
generally but it's a serious question we
have to think about if we think about
all of this from a social point of view
third question is is this really social
knowledge at all something that strikes
me I'm officially a social theorist
whatever that is
but then I often think more Mark
Zuckerberg is the highest-paid social
theorists in the world and I'm never
going to get close to his rewards
because the branding of Facebook is
based around social theoretical claims
there's a whole website we whereas occur
very interesting and many ways
impressive a rich comments on what
Facebook is trying to do is gather their
and here's one particular one where he
said that I think was around 2010 when
they were developing the social graph
and developing that to a higher level
he said we believe that eventually
almost all apps you use are going to be
social but in the world that's a social
world I guess there's a natural spectrum
from behaviors that are really naturally
social to ones that aren't and the ones
that are naturally social are going to
be the ones that turn into social apps
so it's somehow if there's an app for it
then it's naturally social but he's also
saying we're engineering this otherwise
it wouldn't happen do you see there's a
very strange for the bifurcated
reasoning here which is necessary for
the brand that has to talk about the
social hang in a Russia bit here because
I want to go on to another problem there
was some ethical problems here a lot of
data is used to modulate behavior there
was some science now developing it was a
big garden article recently about those
within the data industry who are
becoming a little worried about this you
may have heard of BJ frog the Stanford
data scientists his science of capped
ology which is gathering data at a micro
level about people in order to seriously
influence their behavior to nudge them
regularly so much so that they never
forget the nudge and they like a ball in
a pinball machine will regularly achieve
certain ends but Justin Harris who work
with them originally raises this
question in the magazine that's
published by The Economist what
responsibility comes with the ability to
influence the psychology of a billion
people where's the Hippocratic oath I
mean do we have an ethics of this
influence on this scale which raises
another issue about the ethics of the
gathering of the data should that the
apps for everything the principle of N
equals all of Big Data that you must
have as much data as possible on every
conceivable dimension
to bring it together to allow the
computing to take place hits against
basic ethical questions should we have
an app for whether I'm truly grieving my
mother or whether I'm really in love
with this person are we already stepping
into territory which is beyond
unacceptable and if so why why is that
unacceptable are we clear about why well
are the questions of intimacy where
which we would not allow data collection
to get into we don't know the answer to
it so I'm just raising these as
questions and this takes me to the
second big problem which I will try and
deal with in five minutes to allow for
broader questions which is the problem
of freedom obviously big data depends on
continuous and tracking of people I
don't need to elaborate at that point
Kevin Kelley the West Coast tech
evangelist says in his new book the
inevitable the tracking is just one of
those twelve dimensions of everything
that is now inevitable and will
constitute the new world I think there's
a problem with this because what he
never talks about is that tracking is
not just a technical possibility it's a
social process as all social knowledge
production is social The Economist's
World Economic Forum and others talk
about social data or data big data as
just oil as exhaust it's just there but
there's no thing that is just there even
physical nature has to be constructed
and configured in a way so we can get
value out of it and the same is true of
human life it has we have to be
configured in such a way that we can be
in generative data relations with
infrastructures so there was no data
that is just there and that means there
has to be a social dimension which is
totally absent in Kelly's finished
vision it has been finished the
beginning that's from his famous new
rules for the new economy article in
1997 where he described the NED as just
a collective interaction spun off of a
trillion objects and living beings
linked together through air in class
I mean that still is view today and the
social just isn't even in there in the
framing and that's a big problem the
logic of N equals or which is the big
data law therefore has social and
ethical costs which in principle it
cannot recognize so we have to be able
to frame the problem in other ways -
which is not to not respect the
mathematics and other skills that go
into generating the data because they're
extremely important okay what can we do
about this
there's a lot of debate about outlying
bad data users and that's relatively
straightforward in principle except then
one of the solutions is often
transparency and and as Helen Nissenbaum
point out machine learning is so complex
that we don't know what we there's a
limit to what we can see in order to be
able to see into machine learning we
can't fully see into it because it is a
nonlinear process which acts feedback
feeds back on itself in ways that cannot
be predicted and can't be seen into so
there may be problems there but they're
not what I want to focus on some people
talk about the effects of continuous
tracking of people making them feel
lacking anxious lacking in confidence
just in East Germany for 1989 the life
of others well that's a serious worry as
well
and there are power relations there but
I don't think it's the fundamental
warrior now this is what I want to focus
on for me the fundamental issue and it's
the one least talked about right now is
the very fact of gathering data itself
that's not to say that all data
gathering is bad of course I'm not
saying that but what we're dealing with
is moving to a social order which is
based primarily on the gathering the
continuous gathering of data from
individuals and the question is is this
fully compatible with what we think are
our values or is there a deep tension
that we seriously have to take seriously
and I think there is a tension
let me immediately say there's some type
of data collection and we might
genuinely want
even on that glass scale in the health
area many people argue that we simply
have to start gathering our health data
to deal with serious disease and I take
those arguments really seriously there
were other people argue that it's better
to know how one's body is functioning on
the micro level and it's good to have
wearables and so on and so forth I don't
dispute that the question is what
happens when this becomes the norm and
when it even becomes the requirement of
insurance companies employers friends
and so on that's a very different social
order from where I just choose to
understand my body better as I try to
run faster that's radically different
possibility even in the health case and
voluntary self-tracking there are major
issues about anonymization the data is
formally anonymized but there's a lot of
debate in the health literature as
whether anonymization is actually
possible so even here even in these
special cases there are worries about
data collection
there are even fundamental issues about
whether certain data must always be
under the control of the individual the
philosopher daniel saw mercy argues that
the person's genome is so fundamental to
who they are and who or what they can be
that it must only be under the control
of the individual licensable if you like
to the wider world the dangers are so
great of allowing it to be in control
anything other than that pacific
individual that's an interesting
question that's a sort of fundamental
limit if you like today to collection
and data circulation which we might
think about so starting to wrap up
they were clearly a critical intention
political tensions developing here for
me the real contradiction is between the
shift to an order based around
continuous tracking which is where we
seem to be going and the notion of
freedom autonomy which we normally think
is at the basis of why we are
democracies why we pride ourselves of
being free societies why we would even
want democracy
without going into any detail for me and
I've looked for a long time the only
philosophical reference point I found
that helps me at all here to get right
to the core is Hegel's notion of he
called it freedom but it's really
autonomy we would say now which he
defined this way very interestingly
freedom is the ability to be with
oneself in the other it took me six
months to understand that so let me give
you a shortcut
he gets absolutely at the beginning of
the 19th century that identity is
relational freedom is relational it
emerges in social relations there's a
material infrastructure that could
include some data collection that's in
the other but that necessity to be with
oneself to bit have the ability to
reflect continuously in one's life about
where one is going what one's not wrong
where what what one's life means in
dialog continuously with others but
always it being one's own reflection no
other entity listening in at every point
or directing that reflection that it for
him
is the core of what human beings are
that is the out of the self about us the
Greek word that is the thing whose
freedom we're talking about so what
we're talking about here is not a danger
for a certain capacity or dimension
we're talking about the very possibility
of being yourself and that for me is
what's at stake if we go without any
qualification or debate down the path of
continuous tracking and that's why I'm
worried about it there's biology here
even not very complex animals worms and
so on need a certain space which they
defend
European Data law is very much related
to this Julie Cohen has written about
this we could I want to allow time for
questions so that I'll just leave that
question hanging and say what I've done
so far I think we've reached the point
where we have big problems about the
production of social knowledge and the
condition of that production which
creates tensions with core values such
as freedom or autonomy which we simply
have to start debating and that means
thinking about all of this as a social
process which we are involved in the
social beings we have a voice in this it
is really important therefore that we
bring together those who produce social
knowledge validly smartly importantly
with those any of us it could include
all of us in this room and anyone who's
interested in what the costs of that the
externalities if you like might be when
transposed to the full social scale and
accumulated over time over decades
that's the issue and I think we need to
be debating it ways forward the law is
obviously one very important way the
European general data protection law
regulations is very interesting because
it actually starts from human rights but
there's Kay Crawford and colleagues
writing out at Microsoft new law lab
made a very interesting point you can
have the best from legal frame what you
want but if it operates in the field of
force where an insurer or an employer
requires you to sign away your data for
perfectly valid conditions of running
their own their employment or selling
you an insurance policy that no
regulation will not help you it's not
designed to help you it's not designed
to interrupt business it's designed to
induce certain checks but if the whole
push is to quasi enforce the giving up
of data then it won't help us so we have
to think about other things in the
health sector Barbarella by Evans one of
the most brilliant legal theorists in
the health sector talks about getting
together it's related to Glenn's work
seriously having a collective
conversation about a different data
collection infrastructure
there would help us bring the problems
to the foreground to talk about them and
try and find collective solutions to
deal with these worries I think that's a
really interesting example from the
health sector but she doesn't come up
with solutions she just proposed it as a
possibility
it's not easy and finally I think and I
draw this partly from Julie Cohen's work
we do have to without in any way
challenging the validity of collecting
data and using it to provide smart
solutions we have to raise the
philosophical question as I said before
that the principle of any rules all
which is valid and interesting
mathematically must at some point count
across our ethical limits and say no you
will not have that data
you must not collect that data because
if you collect that you damage the
integrity of what I am and what you are
and that's why I think it's an
interesting problem that we just got to
think about a lot more so thank you for
listening sorry I wax lyrical went on
slightly beyond my time but I hope we
have time for questions and don't have
to finish exactly at 5:00 that's that
okay so when they go back to the slide
sorry I so much to say
sort of discussion of the problems of
statistics so we key has this vision in
which like the problem with statistics
for the attempt to essentially organize
an economy's and statistics is that
statistics are these aggregate course
things that don't pick up the
particularity of the annual situations
and that the beauty of the market
allegedly is that it delegates to quote
the man on the spot who has this much
more granular data it seems like if you
substitute the word market therefore
sort of the autonomous free society or
something like that and the idea is that
once you start getting that granularity
collected in this automated way either
individual cells get delocalized they
have some identity that is not related
to their local surroundings and then the
role that plays in society or they sort
of disappear entirely which was sort of
what you were pointing towards so I sort
of maybe it's not even really a question
but it's it's a it's just an interesting
yeah well I think it is interesting
because it first of all because it zeros
in and the fundamental question here
which is about what is it to know the
social world and how that was one of the
things that drove its work the puzzles
about that obviously that's extremely
interesting and clearly I'm not
suggesting from one moment that somehow
statistics offer better knowledge of the
social compare with what we have today
I'm just looking at the social
externalities the costs of this model
and that's what I what my focus is there
are many arguments to say that we will
understand if we go down in talents more
many aspects of the social better than
before and that's what psychology is
being driven by today and so on but that
incidentally is why I find those who
work for example with BJ Fogg at
Stanford who've been through the very
smartest learning of what you can do
with analytics to predict behavior with
extraordinary precision are still are
the ones particularly troubled by where
this is leading that's already puts one
the sign there are there is more to
debate here but there's the question in
the future of the self well of course
that's a great
point I have no idea where this is
heading
I think Kevin Kelley implies in his
writing that we should slough off this
bother
18th 19th century sense of our
particular individuality it's came out
of a certain phase of the Enlightenment
possessive individualism and so on and
so forth and moved to a different phrase
Jeremy Rifkin Wharton Business School's
made a similar argument in a zero cost
some society whatever the tax of his
book is so the privacy's literary in it
in eighteenth-century notion we should
just get over it but this of course
ignores the deep if almost a cultural
core of privacy the notion culture there
is of course a privacy varies
continuously of course so does autonomy
our sense of what it is to be autonomous
but as I said you only have to go to
relatively simple or complex animals and
they unless they are swarm animals which
is a different case will defend a space
around the self from where the
environment begins that is the space of
that entity we're talking if you like
about that I think that at the core of
all the discussions of privacy autonomy
with all their confusions and messiness
which is a problem there's a certain
minimal notion of the integrity of the
self which I would defy anyone to say we
can dispense with and still be yourself
it's true we can move into a collective
being but I have yet to meet anyone who
actually wants that even think when we
think about the costs but it could have
the debate and in a sense one can't
debate it it will be a fundamental phase
shift in human humanity but I don't
think we're at least ready to get there
yet even if we tell myself yes good to
see you
sorry dystopian view of history where
humans created business you know first
there were bakeries and little
mom-and-pop businesses and they served
us and they grew and they grew and then
they turned into contemporary
corporations and what we're seeing is
sort of the takeover of human autonomy
by the world of business it feels like
fundamentally it's not simply an issue
around surveillance per se but that this
is you know you talked about it being
private entities as opposed to like the
government that's almost ostensibly
doing it for the public that these are
these private entities that our society
has given birth to yeah that are turning
on the Cabal and devouring I've did
that's not what I was saying it but it's
a feeling that comes out a little bit in
this happy to be supported by the
surveillance of the private and when you
talk about the way forward I think an
interesting way of thinking about it is
to look at what are some of the big
problems we want solved you know an
obvious when you mentioned is health
which says well show the insurance
agencies are collecting all of this data
they have to use that data to for health
and to look bigger both at issues around
what is it that we want to see and into
these increasingly opaque entities and
institutions because very little of this
is about
the observant eye into other things so
if you Princeton's think about the
environment or think about how different
the unforeseen consequences are the way
that money that is given to support
certain types of farms has ended up
having because the consequences we don't
want is how do we use this type of data
to better understand these institutions
that have grown extremely opaque and
focus on the kind of big challenges that
may involve data but it's not
necessarily data about it oh well I mean
I'm glad you asked that because of
course I tried to make it clear but I'm
nothing against data collection I'm not
against data processing I said that a
few times that's not a problem it's a
new capacity that we have that we need
to nurture and think about what I'm
raising is the question which is that if
I'm right or even half right
that there's a difference in the overall
social deal which you like through which
knowledge of the world is now being
generated and compared with a rally
comparison in the 19th 20th century
which is simply about a question of
where it goes on the sorts of purposes
for which data was controlled and how
far those are fully open for debate
visible and so on and whether the pros
said that's all I was saying
there's no sense was an anti-business
track because yeah
of course I was making an emphasis
rhetorically because it's try and get
our attention but but they think you're
right so important and I just come back
to that because you're right clearly the
big data could be turned to solve
certain problems which we all want to
solve in ways that could be fully
accountable and useful and that will be
wonderful and just saying we're not yet
at the position to have the social
architecture to deal with the possible
externalities and the data collection
and the data processing that's the
question I'm raising those externalities
are fundamental and deep
we're so assuming that the subject of
the surveillance is always humans
oh no the show thinking war that there's
a lot of opaque entities that maybe we
could bring a lot more surveillance oh
absolutely
again I wasn't saying surveillance of
non-human subjects or other entities was
was a problem that I was focusing on the
human problem because I think that's
where we start from but thank you
now there's lots about I have to better
wrap a few together and then try and the
word privacy wasn't too much in here
because it seems like a lot of these
social problems we usually put in the
privacy I get but there especially after
like the Equifax hack when most
Americans social security numbers are
now public like it doesn't seem that
people get very upset about privacy so I
thought there was something very
productive about moving to the language
of freedom instead so could you talk a
little bit about the move from privacy
to freedom what is driving that yeah
I'll take a few together about
comparison and in the first place was
interesting to me that you mentioned it
was useful to compare big David an older
moment of statistical sort of expansion
and you pointed I get their similarities
and differences and you sort of wonder
okay why compared to that moment in time
and not to something else because that
one or time you know if there's scale
there's numbers and that sort of thing
but there's not continuity there's
nothing things that you mention that are
different you might find other
comparisons that might give you those
things that are not there in stats but
yeah not easily Ellison so one
comparison can I do because you
mentioned fog is behaviorism and
the people who are doing this kind of
like you know fog behavior design kind
of thing and what Kristen Harris is
talking about is a critique or advocacy
for a kind of behaviorist think it's not
exactly the same as behaviors and their
similarities and differences again but
it does bring you back specifically the
question of freedom because it seemed to
me like yeah was it clear to me why
continuous tracking actually was a
threat to autonomy I imagine that if you
asked a lot of people who advocate for
it now they say no no no it's not
necessarily that at all it's an
potentially empowering no-show and a
link maybe to the to the threat of
autonomy come nexia this sort of like
skinner box notion of the social and
that might be a sort of connection that
you make of it okay these have great
questions off take a few together yeah
similar questions about so what's
different now that we have big data and
and and what is this category in
relation to some of the ways social
knowledge was produced before there was
data and still being produced now's I'm
thinking you said well deed is
continuous I thought well that's
interesting because actually it's not I
mean that's what's funny about data is
you take it a chunk here you take a
chunk here and it's not like life at all
that way and I say you know what's
another way to think about social
knowledge and that were like live
performance things happening and now and
I'm think a lot about music and music is
certainly a form of social knowledge and
a way of understanding order of
experiencing certain tensions and
collaborations and that's you know like
that goes on right yeah so there are
these forms of knowledge that go on and
you learn about the world and it creates
a sense of order and now you have big
data so but then what's the relationship
between the two is now big data more
important somehow then these other I was
also thinking gossip I mean gossip is
exactly this exposure of knowledge
that's supposed to be private and has
this interesting reverse power potential
and that still goes on today
so then what's so that's why I'm like
I'm I think I'm with you on the big data
but I'm like what about all the other
staff in place combination between those
two great point um should I take those
three and then there's the Greeks let me
see
privacy yeah that's quite deliberate I
didn't mention where privacy because
there's no clear resolution yet about
how we reconfigure the concept of
privacy to fit this massive
reconfiguration of social knowledge
knowledge gathered gathering and this is
a big problem I'm Julie Cohen's been
writing about it Mary Hildebrandt in
Holland and others therefore all those
writers are trying to get underneath the
concept to privileges something deeper
that might enable sis to reconfigure it
because old if you're like 19th century
liberal privacy about here's your garden
no one can enter your garden it's just
absurd they are already in your garden
they are in your plants and so on that's
absurd so we have to have a totally
different thinking of what privacy is
and we need to dig down to deeper values
and autonomies one make what happens to
call it freedom buddy means what we mean
by autonomy even though that word is
itself a bit problematic as the idea of
the law and there but when you get to
how Hegel describes it he doesn't mean
the private the liberal individual
subject at all he means something
radically different profoundly
relational so that's why I think it's
helpful so yes that's exactly what I'm
trying to do from there we can move back
to privacy and that's what people like
going in legal theory are trying to do
the question of comparison that's great
I mean I write about behaviorism in
another part of the book so that is
interesting and another part of the
argument that I didn't give you you have
a chance to fill in in here is whether
there's been a long move in the 20th
century which is very different from the
19th century move around statistics to
thin out our sense of the social subject
quite radically behaviorism was part of
that revived behaviour and could be seen
as part of that some talk about big data
like Chris Anderson's notorious article
in the theory is very emphatically about
hangout the human subject in saying we
just don't need to know about any of
that squishy stuff that is now please
are those are almost self parodying
positions but they're pretty influential
and there were some people who argue
that within neuro economics and the some
versions of that there are certain
tendencies now I'm not I'm not going to
claim to pronounce on your economics cuz
it's a complex area but I had some more
that is in the book I just fell the
biggest the largest comparison one can
make to get a sense of where we are on
the social level is the 19th century
that is why I presented it for you now
in very interesting point you're right
about continuity I mean continuity of
the collection in time but behind that
is a very complex question which is
really interesting which is the data to
count regularly across space has to
generate continuities at the level of
calculation in comparison which are not
there in the raw stuff that is made into
data now that's a deep point about what
data does and what you should do so
that's that means there are all sorts of
areas of life which don't really fit so
well into that Nancy writes about the
use of their marvelous aspects of how
music claims to be a musician is
enhanced by social networking profoundly
which I've been a musician to dates it's
just a much better and easier life to
connect in various ways it's extremely
interesting however I think there is a
real issue about what cannot be included
in this type of knowledge my co-writer
Ulysses Mathias has written about the
paranoia as he calls it the raw stuff of
life that lies around the node that by
definition cannot be put into data and
therefore it's literally not just
invisible it simply isn't there for
counting that's a really big question
about how the social is being
transformed and that then leads to a
point that everything in the end comes
down and this is why we need historical
comparisons of what can be said about
the social if the aspects of life which
we just are in and live
unregistered in the journal narratives
that are available to be told about the
social there's a certain dislocation may
be a very important there's always
dislocation to some degree but that's I
think an area interesting and that's
where I'm working in other aspects of
the book so thanks for raising that but
there were more questions so I need to
go fast that seems to very much push
against the Hegelian notion of autonomy
that you can be many people at one time
that's a great point yeah great point
there's another one do you have Tom yeah
try and take one or two more yeah the
question I thought I'd need to ask was
you have a you have a concern about the
ethics of data collection and you don't
sometimes talk about an annotated data
collection our private capacity data
collection there's also a continued
state collection there's also say
something like social scientific
academic short I was gonna ask you are
you focusing on the private one because
it's the most pressing or do you think
the problems are universal but but now i
wanna just the question look there's
someone in the image asking because that
makes me think maybe what you're
interested in is the institutional
production of social knowledge i mean
there's a whole set of questions about
other forms of social knowledge that
aren't always in the hands they're there
in certain hands about others like you
know microsoft's talking all about like
democratizing AI yeah but I think
they're just a there's a whole lot of
mechanism
sighs hmm right so like I'm still not a
position where I could do big data
collect yeah but but I can't do some
music right there right so right ready
is it the sort of like the pressure of
this very particular institutional order
so phonology production that's coming in
these places the kind of institutions
that could do it at scale and it's like
available and Knox but it's also felt
yeah that's a very interesting question
just going back to the previous one
about memory I did mention in passing I
was going so much to say in 30 minutes
just clear that's very important which
is that because data is archived and
stored with a stamp as it were the
particularity at the moment and could be
reused again at a later time maybe in a
very different context this creates all
these problems of contextual integrity
that Helena sandbar writes about that's
that's fundamental now you could
certainly argue that the result of that
is to interfere with this is a temporal
integrity of the self and that's another
layer of problem which i think is
important I mean everyone remembers I'm
sure that truly gut-wrenching moment
when Facebook at the end of the person's
year sent to a father who happened to be
a techie the picture of his daughter who
died that year saying any relations with
this person that was he wrote a
wonderfully eloquent blog called
algorithmic cruelty which was
gut-wrenching because he understood
exactly how it happened but he also felt
pained in the deep as possible said this
this this is absolutely wrong and yet
it's generated by process as I
understand so I think you're right when
we move on to the temporal side there
are even more issues about the question
of integrity I think that for me that
reinforces the argument unless you think
we've gradually become used to this
chamber I think we absolutely do not
become used to these changes from that's
a sort of simple crude example so I'm
sure there's more we could talk about
but thank you for raising the time
question tarleton that's a great point
I'm using the word public private here
simply to signal a different
assemblage of knowledge authority trust
and so on which is and therefore
relatively crude and it doesn t seem map
on to certain types of institutions
simply and the state of course remains
profoundly interested in private data
collection I mean you may not know but
in Britain the British government
seriously debated about four or five
years ago until something stopped it
it's not clear what abandoning the
national census about five years ago
there was a small debate about that on
the basis that far better data was being
gathered all the time by private
organisations the state was running out
of money why not just defer that
fundamental Faculty of the state which
is to know its population in order to
govern so I think there are very
interesting relations between the state
and part which raise massive political
theory questions but you are implying
the question which goes back to glens
which i think is a really serious point
well couldn't we imagine that with a
different assemblage a different
configurational authority trust and so
on we could consent to more data being
gathered about ourselves and their being
stored I don't deny that for a moment
that's why I pointedly mentioned the
health case but that will require very
different social architecture from what
we have at the moment I know as the
source in the Glen is exactly interested
in but I think I'm trying to point out
these extremely difficult questions to
generate such a social architecture it's
never been done in the past it's only
been done by States which did not
successfully generate trust we don't
barely know how to solve that higher
dimensional interdependence problem so
I'm exposing the problem yes it will be
great if we have better solutions
because we're not going to stop data
collection and I would love it to be
puts more positive thing but I think
we're barely at the beginning of even
posing the question let alone sorry
thank you so much for your talk with I'm
struck by often when having just the
day-to-day conversations about
collecting data it's it's less than a n
equals all and more of an end of
everything I can get oh yes I Slee the
yes I ain't getting what I can show
without the possibility of the
disruption of requesting consent because
that might impinge on either the
representative sample but then this
really odd disconnect I don't know if
it's a disconnect what do you make of
the willingness to say one I'll work
with what I can get and I'm gonna
extrapolate out from there it's not as
though I've ever talked with any
engineer in this in this area that said
what we really need is a sensor on every
person every baby every second none of
them feel like that's necessary no
precisely because they imagine that what
they're working out is a new statistics
to extrapolate put Jack yeah there's no
engineer who feels like that's necessary
and I think it perhaps goes back to your
diagnosis of and a certain set of
assumptions about the natural state of
the human being yeah so what do you what
do you miss that why I'm thinking about
the end well that's obviously very
encouraging that in other words
implicitly there is resistance I'm not
claiming any special there's a sort of
resistance here well right right but the
babies I mean and that of course is the
older model of building statistical
knowledge which didn't raise this sort
of externality problem that I'm talking
about but I think if it's a looks
rather differently if you go study what
how marketers are talking about the
gathering information their business
model is about gathering all information
at all times and hoping to use it for
example there's a interesting report on
the future of wearable words by
Price Waterhouse Cooper came out there
four years ago and Totoro talks about in
his book on the shopping Marlin and
surveillance which seriously without
irony or humor suggested well if
everyone started to have a wearable
built in which was continuously tracking
the state of their body and continues to
be matched with a match with all the
available marketing information about
what they like and what they don't they
could be told where you're you're sweaty
now maybe you should get a bottle of
water but we know you like that store
around the corner but they're offering a
special deal and so on in other words
what I'm trying to get at is the core
conception which has some spurious basis
in certain stories about big data to be
more explicit this is not good science
it's a certain story that Anderson
others are told and something very very
practical fix it in the marketing world
which are working to install the
possibility of any equals all as a
default setting and McKinsey's have
written reports arguing that we need
that default setting of assuming the
data will be collected that I think
raises questions
it's just I'm glad you mentioned
marketing so in the spaces that I study
where this proposition of data
collection is always present it's very
much abetted in marketing than that guys
yeah but it often still feels as if it's
a well there's two things that I think
of there's a spam ulis stuff on peak ads
we sort of have already at the moment
where this the promise of advertisement
marketing is it's it's not there's a
rhetoric of it a missus of it but it's
not where things really are and so the
big day this stuff is participating in a
rhetoric that is really needs to be
revisited and so I just so I'm glad you
mentioned the marketing cuz I do wonder
how we make sense of these tensions that
sort of drive to revive of marketing an
advertising model that actually has a
lot of empirical fragility to it that
many people actually in the space know
[Music]
well I mean again you're pointing to the
fact there are complex cultural tensions
being worked out in that's good and
that's as we would expect if this is a
social process but I I can't deny I've
been very struck by Joseph to Rose
account of the retail marketing area
which doesn't see the type of resistance
and drawback that you're talking about
it may be different in different sectors
so clearly the position picture is still
emerging and I'm trying to draw a
journal narrative out of this and say
that if we would continue entirely in
this direction there will be these major
concert hence my alarm bell but I'm glad
to hear that and music might be a
special case I don't know that's good or
game the game is you might be very
interesting we should talk more about
that yeah
right got it well we should talk more
and I hope you're right but if you look
I've also been doing a study of the big
discourse about big data collection
World Economic Forum the leading spokes
organizations for business global
business and they're not making any
concessions at all in their language
about this and their reports have some
weight and so that's another of my
sources line behind the report but it's
luckily a common complex picture more
complex and they painted to foreground
the questions then do you want to get
serviced in various ways in social
context undermines my control or my
relationship time perceives socially
understood by other people and what I'm
able to do on my own because of how it
will be perceived by others that's sort
of one issue set of issues and that
seems to raise issues about you have to
have humility these otherwise you get
coerced to share things and the ways
that you're describing it's over there's
another set of issues where actually
it's the recommendations that are coming
back to me and my willingness to accept
those and the power of what's being
offered to me that's actually the threat
to autonomy
and there's erosion of the individuals
real authority over her own yeah choices
and and those seem to me actually be two
somewhat separate things which are both
threatening I'm this is great I mean
they it autonomy is once you start to
open it out and rework with it from now
is a very complex concept that we need
to fill in in lots of new way so I
wouldn't disagree with that for a moment
I think they're actually directly
connected though because Hegel's view
and this is why I find it so compelling
is that there never was of a final
stability of the self is endlessly
changing in mutual relations with others
while still trying to go on making sense
of itself so as you say the
recommendations we receive from others
that we integrate into our sense of
ourselves are really crucial to that now
I've been reading today and discussing
in another reading group over at Bertman
tomorrow here's the Karen young piece on
the hyper nudge and in there anyway it's
quite a new piece by a legal theorist at
King's College London taking the simple
liberal notion of the nudge relatively
innocent why not encourage people to eat
slightly more healthily or whatever it
might be by placing things differently
so which in itself is not in any way
offensive to liberal principles although
it's been debated with the hyper
knowledge which is installing nudging at
almost every point in a million point
space so that every point the self comes
up against you can immediately see you
start to get the feedback looks I'm
talking about it here's her argument is
that this is in principle necessarily
opaque and therefore it must interfere
with that autonomy we thought the
subject had to frame its choices about
choices its second-order choices they
are the core and that is really
interesting so I think the two linked
together and that is why I just want to
raise the question isn't the way the
continuous data collection as a default
on norm doesn't have and the play
Bax that necessarily come from that when
we all surveilled each other is of
course we do I do as much as anyone
creates externalities moral ethical
practical and also in terms of social
legitimacy for the institutions we we
need for markets and other things which
we just have to think about so that's
I'm raising the question thank you
[Applause]